all right let's get on
to what's going on for the forecast uh
friday looks
fantastic as well we've got a little bit
of wind coming back though for your
weekend and making a lot of wind coming
back
for saturday a little bit on sunday lots
of 40s out there it's
very mild right now and we're doing fine
light winds
here's your friday though look how much
warmer we're going to be we're reaching
for
mid 70s today normal high 67
and we'll look for that sunset at 5 40.
again just a reminder we're on standard
time we don't change our clocks till
next weekend
just want to keep telling people that
people keep asking me when is it we
change our clocks
it's it's coming really late it seems
like but it is the second sunday of
march
chilly in the northeast rain in the
southern plains and we're looking at
wind across the northwest we're going to
get a taste of that wind tomorrow
as a little piece of energy dives
through california right into southern
nevada that's what's going to kick up
the winds
for saturday the strongest winds
tomorrow a little breezy on sunday
55 up into mount charleston today
beautifully mild not much in the way of
the wind up there
but again it will get windy tonight
through tomorrow mid 70s out at the lake
some south breezes but tomorrow those
winds are going to be 25 30 miles an
hour so please don't forget the life
jackets they've had to make rescues out
there from kayakers and swimmers lately
upper 70s tomorrow with those windy
conditions mid 70s on sunday
next week unsettled and cooler look at
this with low 60s and slight chances for
rain
by the middle of the week our